the same thing that makes this question
we're about to do really wonderful
is also what makes it a little bit
monstrous when you look at this question
um i kind of compared to like the tour
de france i don't know if you
are into cycling at all but the twitter
france is this
you know multi-stage race it goes for
more than three weeks and you cover
hundreds and hundreds of kilometers
it's just really long and when you have
a look at it you can see the length of
this question
um there are a lot of very you know
sections you have to be very patient and
persevere through to get there
but not only is something like the tour
de france long um it also has
these uh very famous climbs that are
really hard and this question
uh it binds together some really
challenging concepts that are
quite disconnected uh normally in our
brains and you kind of have to
combine them and see how they fit
together in order to solve
this entire question you know for
starters you can see demarva's theorem
you know a pretty classic result in
complex numbers
starts out the question but then we get
into polynomials and you have to also
use some fancy trigonometric identities
in order to get to the end of this so
buckle in
uh you might need to have like something
to eat and drink nearby because
this is going to take some time but
let's see if we can start off and make
some progress
with this the question begins use the
marvelous theorem to prove the identity
and then it has to do with cos 6 alpha
on the left hand side
and then a bunch of because alphas and
other coefficients and powers
on the right hand side so we're being
prompted to use demarva's theorem so
that's where we're going to begin
so what is demarva's theorem let's
remember it's a general result
for raising complex numbers to a power
so we would say
what that looks like for in general
terms is that
if you take some complex number cos
theta plus i
sine theta and if you raise it to an
integer power n you can say
that all that does is it actually uh
multiplies
all of the arguments the theta in this
case by n
so you get this result here now
for the question that this has been
presented to us it's got a 6
in there on the left hand side cos 6
alpha so
i guess what they're suggesting is we
take an argument of alpha and we take
an n of 6. that's going to give us the
result that we want
so i'm going to start off with actually
what's written on the
right hand side here because it's
simpler i'm going to say
by demarva's theorem cos 6
theta or alpha rather because i think
that's the angle provided to us
plus i sine 6 alpha equals
and then it's just going to be the
complex number with alpha as an argument
raised to the power of 6. now at this
point
you would be understood uh it's
understandable to kind of wince at this
because
we are used to expanding things to the
power of two sometimes the power of
three we seldom go
beyond that but using our knowledge of
binomial coefficients we absolutely
can handle this so long as we take care
and do everything
methodically so i'm going to start to
expand this but just before i do
um obviously there's going to be a lot
of terms here you know a
binomial raised to the power of 2 has
three terms in it a squared plus two ap
plus two a b plus b squared um something
raised to the power of three has four
terms
this is raised to the power of six so
they're going to be seven terms it's
gonna be a lot of different things
flying around
and for that reason i'm going to write
it in a slightly unusual way
i'm going to write the terms in two
different columns
in a minute you might be able to see why
so as i write down these terms let's see
if you can anticipate
the reason for my particular arrangement
let's begin
when we're doing this binomial expansion
the first thing that comes in
is the binomial coefficient 6 c0
and then we're going to get a 6
a 6th power of the first term which in
this case is cos
alpha so cos alpha to the power of 6.
then comes the next term so we get the
binomial coefficient
we have one less power of the first term
and then we have one more power
of the second term so it's you know this
one's decreasing this one is
increasing i promised i would put
answers in two columns so the next one
is going to be
6 c 2 the cosine is climbing down so 6
then 5 then 4
and then i've got i sine alpha it's
being
squared uh where am i two okay six
c three this bit you can sort of be on
autopilot as you're expanding this
uh cos cubed alpha i sine
alpha that's cubed so we're kind of in
the middle now
plus uh six c for
cos what are we up to squared alpha
i sine alpha i'm now to the power of
four
our powers of course are our indices
rather they're always adding up to
six two plus four then my next one
there's second to last
six c5 i've only got one cos alpha left
and then i'm going to get this to the
power of five and then finally i've got
6 c6 and then no more cosines i've only
got the i
sine alpha that's raised to the power of
6.
okay so this is a lot
right and i i've not expanded anything
i've literally just
not expanded any of these particular
terms is what i'm saying i've just done
the initial expansion
raising to this power of six but uh what
am i going to do with this well i want
you to have a look at what's on the left
hand side
and compare that to what's on the right
hand side when you
compare these two and look back at the
original question
clearly the thing that i'm interested in
is cos
6 alpha this thing here which you can
see appearing on
the left-hand side it's the real
component of the complex number on the
left-hand side
so as a consequence of wanting just to
focus on this
i can somewhat ignore all of the things
that are imaginary and this is why
i wrote things into columns if you have
a look over here
the things that i wrote on this right
hand column right
all of these guys over here have an odd
multiple of not odd multiple and odd
power
of i um you can see this is i to the
power of 1
so that's going to have an i when i
factorize that it'll be imaginary
this is i cubed now i squared is
negative 1
so that will i cubed is equal to
negative i so
again when i factorize it out there will
be an i out the front it's going to be
imaginary and the same thing happens
here i to the power of 5
is the same as either power of 4 times i
i to the power of 4
is just 1 so it kind of cancels out
leaving you with a single eye that comes
out the front
so what i'm trying to say is all of can
i get the right spot yeah there we go
all of these terms here kind of become
irrelevant to me because
they are the imaginary component that
relates to this
the ones i'm really interested in are
these real components
over here because they have uh even
powers of i
uh they are going to give me just real
results when i start doing
the simplifying so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to say
i'm going to just compare the real parts
comparing
the real parts now i'm going to kind of
do this
a little bit cheekily on the left hand
side i of course have the cos
6 alpha but in order to get the right
hand side correct
i need to actually do a bit of
simplifying at the same time
you can see i'll just leave the binomial
coefficients for a second we'll
do that afterwards this guy here cos to
the power of 6
alpha it never had any eyes in it to
begin with so i'm just going to leave it
like so
but here when i'm comparing the real
path there shouldn't be any eyes
floating around right
so instead of writing i squared i'm
going to substitute that for
-1 and then when instead of writing i to
the power of 4
i'm going to substitute that for 1. and
lastly instead of writing out a power of
6 i've looped back to being minus 1.
okay so what have i got here the first
one this is going to be
minus that's the i squared that you
might remember uh
6 c 2 cos to the 4
alpha and then i get a sine squared
alpha like so
i then get zoom out a bit my next one is
6 c 4 and we said this i to the power of
4 is just 1
so i get my cos squared alpha and then
i've got sine
to the power 4 alpha and then my last
term
is going to be 6 c 6
that's that i to the power of six is is
that minus sign which i should have
written out the front there
um and then i just get sine
to the power of six alpha okay great
so this is an improvement um i'm already
not dealing with as many terms as i had
in the original expansion um but there's
a few issues with this
aren't there um for starters i haven't
dealt with my binomial coefficients yet
six c0 6a2 and so on
and the other thing that my mind is sort
of realizing
is on the right hand side over here the
result i'm trying to prove
it doesn't have any signs in it it's all
cosines so
i'm clearly going to need to do
something uh with these terms here this
sine squared this side to the power 4
and this sine to the power of 6. i'm
going to have to address
those and get them in terms of cos
so we'll come to that in a second let's
deal with the binomial coefficients
now anything any integer c0 is just
going to be one
and any integer c itself is also going
to be one
but maybe you can't remember these 6 a 2
and 6 c 4 because
you know you haven't looked at them for
a while so whoopsie daisy on your
calculator
what you want to do is find the uh six
and then the the c is sort of above the
division there so you need to go shift
um to get the c and then if i go six
c two um then you might be able to just
make out
if that's going to focus properly
there we go 62 that should give you 15.
and so
you can actually also verify that 64
will give you the same result
so what i'm going to get is this will be
one this will be one and then these two
are 15. so let's
simplify that uh here comes the one
because
to the six uh alpha minus fifteen
of these guys here
uh fifteen of these as well
and then one at the end there
okay so this is looking good now
we already sort of signaled for
ourselves that we were going to have to
replace these signs
with cosines the most helpful identity
here of course is going to be the
pythagorean identity
you might remember as a sine squared
plus cos
squared being equal to 1. but clearly if
we want to remove
sine squareds out of it then the way to
rewrite this in a more helpful form is
to subtract
cos squared from both sides so this is
what i'm going to substitute into each
of these spots
however i do want you to notice if you
look closely here
the sine squared alpha i can just
substitute that directly but this sine
to the power of 4
alpha this is sine squared alpha
squared by my index laws and this guy
over here
is going to be sine squared alpha cubed
also by index laws so what i'm going to
have to do is substitute this 1 minus
cos squared into here and there'll be
some further expansion that i have to do
but that's fine
all right let's have a go so i've got
cos to the power of 6
alpha minus 15 cos to the 4
alpha and then here comes my first use
of the pythagorean identity
1 minus cos squared
here comes the next one so i've got a
cos squared here
and then 1 minus cos squared
gets squared that's me doing this
substitution into here
and then finally i've got 1 minus
cos squared and that's being cubed
okay so you can see here i might just
for the sake of clarity i'll change
these to another
color let's make them pink um i can
uh do this expansion here on the next
line i'm just going to want to take care
with it because i can see there's lots
of there's minus signs
there's lots of terms that need to be
expanded so i'm going to take some
some care with that and some caution so
this is going to get expanded i'll write
that in red when i get to it
and this is also going to get expanded
i'll write that in blue
all right let's begin chipping away at
the boulder so cos to the 6 alpha
here i've got this term multiplied by 1
in the first instance so that's minus
15 cos to the 4 alpha and then
just watch out because there's a double
negative here right minus 15 cos
the 4 alpha is multiplied by minus cos
squared alpha
so the negatives will cancel giving me
plus and then
15 times 1 just gives me 15. um and then
if you have a look closely at the
indices you've got to power 4 here
and then to the power of 2. so adding
those indices together you get to the
power of
six okay now for this next part here i'm
i'll fit this first part on this line
i've got the 15 cos
squared alpha coming out the front but
then 1 minus cos squared alpha
squared is going to be 1
minus 2 cos squared alpha plus
cos to the power of 4 alpha so
hopefully you agree with that expansion
there you can see
this is my a squared minus 2a b
plus b squared okay and then i'm coming
to this one at the end there's a minus
sign
just right at the front there so i write
that down first and then here comes my
expansion
um with me cubing this so again i'm
using my binomial coefficients
we cube things relatively frequently
compared to raising things to the power
of six
so i know my binomial coefficients my
row of pascal's triangle is 21331
so here comes my expansion i'm going to
go one
and then i'm going to go you've got to
watch out right because there's a minus
sign here so that comes along for the
ride
the first one is going to be minus 3
cos squared alpha then i get a plus
because the plus minus keeps alternating
the next binomial coefficient is
3 and then this cos squared gets
squared so that gives you cos power 4
alpha
lastly you can see i'm now cubing this
the binomial coefficient
is going to be 1. so i get minus
1 because that minus comes from this
minus being done three times
and then there's cos the power of 6
alpha
so i know i did that really quickly if
this
expansion here was the one giving you
trouble and what i would suggest is you
go back to your notes on
binaural expansions and revise that work
here having the the trig stuff in there
and having the minus
does make it there's an additional level
of cognitive load stuff in your brain
you have to
get out of your working memory and so
hopefully that's something which you can
contend yourself with as we go along all
right
now when i have a look at this i know
it's messy but it's actually really
encouraging because number one i've
dealt with all the binomial coefficients
number two everything is in terms of
cosines which is
um that is what i was what i was hoping
for right it looks like the difference
between this and the line that i've got
is just
collecting like terms there's a bunch of
cos the power of six alphas a bunch of
cost power four alphas and i just need
to arrange them okay
now i need more colors here so i'm gonna
do this um
so that i can uh you know expand this
out nicely and
identify the right terms so i'm getting
because of the sixth alpha here minus 15
cos to the
4 alpha i've already multiplied and
expanded this guy here
and then let's have a look so 15 cos
squared alpha is going to be multiplied
by all three terms
in here in these red brackets so the
first one will give me
15 cos squared alpha because i'm
multiplying by 1.
then i've got 15 times -2 so that gives
you minus 30
and when i look at the powers it's cos
the power of 4 alpha and then the last
one
will be 15 cos to the power of 6
alpha and i get that from this
multiplied by this term
okay for the next one i don't have any
big number coefficients i just have to
take care of this minus it's just going
to flip everything around
so i'm going to get a minus 1 plus 3
cos squared alpha minus 3 cos to the 4
alpha plus cos to the 6
alpha i'll just double check i've
reversed that sign to this has become
positive
this has become negative this becomes
positive happy times
all right now like i said i need more
colors
so i'm looking for my cos the six alphas
and collecting them in like terms so
here's the first one here is the second
one
here is the third one and then here is
the fourth one there
and so you can see i'm going to get
whoopsie daisy
just sort of preempting what my working
will be there's 30
of them here and then an extra two so
that's 32 and when i look
that's a relief that i've expanded
everything correctly and it seems like
i'm on
the right track so i'll write that in
orange shortly
i also have um we'll do it in this and
i've got cos the power of four alphas so
here's one
there's one uh here's another one and
then my last one is over here
so having a look at that um they're all
negative so uh
minus 15 and then minus 30 is minus 45
and then minus
3 again is minus 48. so again have a
check things are looking good
and then the rest of the terms i i think
we should be able to manage because
there
aren't nearly as many of them okay so i
promise i'll write this in orange
because
i've highlighted the orange how many
colors the six alphas have i got
uh we said 32 so 32
cos uh to the six alphas
um let's go to green next so how many
cost the fours i think we said was 48
close to the four alphas and then we'll
switch back to our normal cover
color how many uh cos squares are there
there's 15 there's three
so i'm getting 18 and then there is one
solitary constant term
minus one so on the left hand side we
had cos
six alpha from memory because you can
see it there from the real part of the
left hand side
32 minus 48 18 negative one minus one
uh it all checks out so that's always
good to know
that we've actually done it all
correctly and so i'll just
conclude that take a breath
so that was uh the first stretch we have
done
the use of de marvelous theorem we've
taken care of our trigonometric
identities done our expanding
um and it looks good we've gotten to the
result that was required